why didn't you quit why why did you
carry on
oh good question um i think for me
a lot of people in recruitment do
compare themselves to others around them
didn't really want to fully focus on
them i knew inside me that i could do it
i could tell myself
eight years ago when i first started it
would would be to
to step outside your comfort zone to be
brave
too even if you don't feel like it some
days
just come in and want to win and give it
100
you're not the most confident person but
you know that you can be
so i wanted to really push myself every
single day to get there
a winning mindset someone that when
a bad thing happens or something
happens that they can't control they
want to find a solution to win
they don't dwell on it they're not
negative a lot around positivity i guess
with their mindset
it's listening so i think it's forgotten
about a lot in recruitment
but if you're a good listener and you
can really listen to your clients and
your candidates and
understand them fully then you're in the
best position
[Music]